the big news of the weekend is this
horrific incident in waukesha wisconsin
according to the uk daily mail at least
five people have been killed and 40
injured including at least 12 children
after a speeding suv plowed into a
christmas parade taking place in a
suburban town near milwaukee on sunday a
red ford escape broke through barriers
in waukesha wisconsin around 4 40 pm as
the parade was taking place drove at
speed through crowds sending bodies
flying his horrified families watched on
helplessly we're not going to show you
the video because it really is pretty
horrific and it doesn't add anything
here you can just see kids marching down
the street and then this ford suv which
you can't really
you have no idea why it's there just
plowing through people apparently some
gunshots were fired as well police
originally said a person of interest was
in custody no arrests had been made
chief daniel thompson said no motive had
been established but the officers are
not discounting it terrorism officers
are also looking into the possibility
the suspect was fleeing an earlier
incident involving a knife when he
reached the parade which would be
unbelievable if this guy was involved in
a knife crime and then was running from
the cops and decided hey while i'm at it
i may as well run over a few school
children
truly an act of evil thompson said one
officer fired at the vehicle in an
unsuccessful bid to stop it with
witnesses saying it's sped along the
parade route and did not slow down even
as it hit a school girls dance troupe
and elderly members of the walking
dancing grannies along with families
sitting by the side of the road
dozens of pieces of footage ended up
capturing the carnage revealing that the
car traveled at least three blocks down
the parade route before breaking through
barriers and speeding away a picture
captured later in an unknown location
showed what appeared to be the vehicle
involved backed onto a driveway with the
hood badly dented and bent up it's
unclear how the vehicle came to be there
police have not revealed exactly how the
suspect was arrested
just horrific all the way through and
there's lots of speculation at this
point about the motive of this person
about whether this person was in fact
involved in an earlier crime that day
i don't on this show talk about the
identities of mass shooters or mass
killers or terrorists i do talk about
who they are and what they did but i
don't reveal names on this show because
we don't wish to inspire copycats or
give attention to some of the worst
people on earth what we do know at this
point is that this person does have a
criminal record he's a 39 year old black
male from milwaukee county a felon and
apparently according to wisconsin right
now milwaukee their court system
suspended his speedy trial rights due to
court congestion they released him on
500 bail even though he was facing a
serious weapons and other felony charge
then even though he was stalked with a
string of new felony charges he was
released again on one thousand dollars
bail three days before the parade
massacre
this guy has a rap sheet as long as your
arm milwaukee county has a really long
backlog of criminal cases and because of
bail reform this notion that if you are
poor you should not be held in jail
because you can't pay the bail so
instead we'll release you onto the
street
for a minimal amount of money like a
thousand dollars now you have criminals
who are back walking the streets and
this is a perfect case endpoint of that
according to judge mary trigiano
we've taken this pandemic very seriously
as well we should including the variants
we're being very careful this is with
regard to the backlogs and the and the
unwillingness to keep people in jail
so a lot of people who have been
committing crimes again are back out on
the streets
on social media the suspect apparently
showed animus toward police
posted on happiness about the kyle
writtenhouse verdict as well as george
floyd's death quoted at malcolm x we
don't have a full motive at this point
what we do know is that this person
should not have been on the street
apparently the department of justice
criminal record history includes many of
these arrests arrested in 1999 for a
carry concealed weapon charge
in 1999 he was also arrested for
aggravated battery felony that was
dismissed concealing carrying a
concealed weapon non-criminal
disposition not reported in 2000 more
arrests for aggravated battery felony
convicted probation
resisting misdemeanor dismissed cocaine
possession misdemeanor 2002 resisting
non-criminal take and drive vehicle
without consent habitual criminal felony
dismissed no prosecution 2003 resisting
misdemeanor convicted 2005 resisting
misdemeanor receiving stolen property
misdemeanor dismissed possessed stolen
possessed controlled substance dismissed
2009 paternity warrant non-criminal
resisting officer non-criminal resisting
misdemeanor convicted 2010 felony
strangulation and suffocation domestic
abuse amended complaint filed convicted
misdemeanor battery dismissed criminal
damage to property dismissed 2011
probation violation felony hold for
probation authorities extradition
request disposition not reported
resisting convicted thc possession
paternity warrant possessed with intent
to deliver thc convicted bail jumping
convicted there's only up to 2011 by the
way he was still another 10 years on
this guy's record ago
2012 probation violation turned over to
probation authorities bail jumping
felony no prosecution failure to appear
multiple bail jumping misdemeanor two
counts no prosecution resisting no
prosecution extradition possess thc
felony case dismissed 2020 firearm
convicted of out-of-state felony charge
issued possession of meth dismissed
endangering safety domestic abuse
reckless use of firearm charge issued
paternity warrant non-criminal
hey again this is according to wisconsin
right now so this guy has a rap sheet
that just goes on forever forever and he
was out on bail on a thousand dollars
bail after having been arrested like
three days beforehand for
bail jumping
so the strategy apparently in in
milwaukee county is somebody jumps bail
if you capture them you should have them
post bail which they will then jump
makes perfect sense but this is brought
part of a broader prosecutorial strategy
that the left has imposed on major
cities across the united states you want
to know one of the reasons why we've
seen a major uptick in crime in major
cities across the united states over the
past few years it's because
prosecutorial strategy has changed
dramatically it's because people like
george soros have poured millions of
dollars over the past seven eight years
into electing left-wing prosecutors
across the country so remember this sort
of activity has been championed by the
left prosecutions prosecutors letting
criminals out of jail
jeffrey tubin who used to be more famous
as a legal commentator now he's more
famous for not being able to keep his
junk in his pants
he wrote a piece in 2015
for new yorker magazine called the
milwaukee experiment what can one
prosecutor do about the mass
incarceration of african americans quote
like many people in the criminal justice
system john chisholm the district
attorney in milwaukee county has been
concerned for a long time about the
racial imbalance in american prisons the
issue is especially salient in wisconsin
where african americans constitute only
six percent of the population but 37
percent of those in state prison
according to a study from university of
wisconsin-milwaukee as of 2010 13 of the
state's african-american men of working
age were behind bars nearly double the
national average of 6.7 percent
the figures were especially stark from
milwaukee county where more than half of
african-american men in their 30s had
served time in state prison how chisholm
wondered did the work of his own office
contribute to these numbers could a da
do anything to change them
now this is the part that's amazing
right because this is the animating
philosophy behind so much of the
democratic party these days if a
disproportionate number of people from a
particular group are in jail it must be
because the system is evil and corrupt
now here's the problem the result of
that sort of thinking means letting
criminals out of jail based on race and
class that's what it means it means that
if you wish to have fewer black people
in jail
you're going to have to either identify
people who are innocent and shouldn't be
in jail or you're going to have to let
criminals out of jail and people who
supposedly need to be let out
on bail
after having jumped bail multiple times
which is apparently what happened in
this particular case in waukesha
chisholm decided to let independent
researchers examine how he used his
prosecutorial discretion
over several years chisholm allowed the
researchers to question his staff
members and look at their files the
conclusions were disturbing according to
the vira study prosecutors in milwaukee
declined to prosecute 41 percent of
whites arrested for possession of drug
paraphernalia compared with 27 percent
of blacks et cetera et cetera et cetera
so chisholm decided his office would
undertake initiatives to try to send
fewer people to prison while maintaining
public safety
how's that going for you over there john
gone great for you is it by the way if
the case is that he's letting too many
white people off then arrest more white
people who are criminals and put them in
prison do not let criminals out of jail
nobody has an interest in letting
criminals out of jail in order to quote
unquote even out the numbers
chisholm said that prosecutors should be
judged by their success in reducing mass
incarceration and achieving racial
equality
how it
excuse me
prosecutors should be judged on how the
crime rates go down that is the only
thing prosecutors should be judged on we
have an adversarial system to protect
defendants it is not the job of
prosecutors to determine
whether mass incarceration is a thing or
achieving quote unquote racial equality
in outcomes is a thing that's not the
prosecutor's job the prosecutor should
not be looking to wait we have too many
black people in prison i guess this
criminal who is black should not be in
prison because he's black that's insane
that's insane and there's a reason why
i've seen a spiking murder rate in
milwaukee over the last couple of years
chisholm's efforts have drawn attention
across the country
cyrus vance manhattan district attorney
said quote john is a national leader in
law enforcement because he is genuinely
interested in trying to achieve the
right results not only in individual
cases but in larger policy issues as
well chisholm reflects a growing
national sentiment that the criminal
justice system has failed african
americans
et cetera et cetera so this has been the
schtick and they stick for a very long
time is that
is that prosecutors of the left are
doing a great job by evening out the
numbers that is the thing that means the
most he said the racial disparity spoke
for itself starting with the disparities
in the state prison system
but there were very significant
disparities in specific categories the
one that stood out the most was
low-level drug offenders possession of
marijuana drug paraphernalia things were
clear there were clearly a disparate
number of african-americans being
charged and processed for these offenses
he says when i first saw the data
i thought here is some good news
because apparently it said that we
charged white offenders for property
crimes at a higher rate than we do black
offenders for those kinds of cases i
thought good here's a disparity the
other way around but a deputy of mine
pointed out what the data really meant
was we devalue property crimes in the
censor city we don't charge a car theft
okay well that's right so then the
question is why are you not charging the
drug distribution cases why are you not
charging the felony bail jumping cases
it's just incredible so the the entire
basis for criminal justice in wisconsin
has been rooted apparently in this
michelle alexander knew jim crow if too
many black people are in prison it's
because america is racist philosophy as
opposed to you're a prosecutor lower the
crime rate by arresting criminals who
committed crimes again if you want to
make a case these people are innocent if
you want to make these cases these
people shouldn't be in jail make the
case they shouldn't be in jail but you
can't make the case they shouldn't be in
jail when they are criminals
and you shouldn't be allowing them to
roam the streets ramming cars into
children because you want to establish
racial equity
are you insane
again the murder rate in wisconsin is
out of control
by the way milwaukee police have only
solved like 58 of homicides last year in
2020 compared to 68
in 2019. the rate thus far this year in
milwaukee is 34
their murder rate is out of control
there are 190 homicides in milwaukee
last year
190.
okay but this is supposed to be a big a
big win
for
this prosecutor
insane
according to the medical college of
wisconsin
there have been 941
victims
in homicides by firearm homicides by
non-firearm or non-fatal shootings in
wisconsin in 2020 okay that is a jump
from 542 in 2019.
so
really well done and here's the problem
this is a national strategy okay this is
not just in milwaukee it's not just in
waukesha okay this is a national
strategy by the left
you can see it happening okay so as i
say this is a broad strategy by the left
okay and it's financed by people like
george soros i know that the media want
you never to say george soros's name
because it's supposedly anti-semitic to
point out that george soros funds wild
left-wing causes he does okay i'm an
orthodox jew i can say whatever the hell
i want about george soros george soros
is a left-wing fanatic and he has spent
billions of dollars
on various left-wing causes around the
globe
he is a very bad man he does very bad
things
and left celebrates him for it politico
reported back in 2016 quotes george
soros's quiet overhaul of the u.s
justice system
quote while america's political king
makers inject their millions into
high-profile presidential and
congressional contests democratic
mega-donor george soros has directed his
wealth into an under the radar 2016
campaign to advance one of the
progressive movement's core goals
reshaping the american justice system
the billionaire financier has challenge
has channeled more than three million
dollars into seven local district
attorney campaigns in six states over
the past year a sum that exceeds the
total spent on the 2016 presidential
campaign by all but a handful of rival
super donors
his money has supported african american
and hispanic candidates for these local
powerful roles all of whom ran on
platforms sharing major goals of sorrows
like reducing racial disparities in
sentencing directing some drug offenders
to diversion programs instead of to
trial it is by far the most tangible
action in a progressive push to find
prepare and finance criminal justice
reform oriented candidates for jobs that
have been held by long-time incumbents
and service pipelines to the federal
courts
andrea dustin president of emerge
america a candidate training
organization for democratic women says
the prosecutor exercises the greatest
discretion and power in the system it is
so important
there's been a confluence of events in
the past couple of years all of a sudden
the progressive community is waking up
to this soros has spent on da campaigns
in florida illinois louisiana
mississippi new mexico and texas this is
as of 2017 through a network of state
level super pacs and a national 527
unlimited money group each named a
variation of safety and justice
each organization received most of its
money directly from soros
and again this is not just in blue
states this is in red states as well
this is how you see left-wing
prosecutors in places like florida
left-wing prosecutors in places like
louisiana
and this stuff has some pretty
predictable effects you know why it's
happening
okay you know why the crime rates are
going up in a wide variety of areas
again fast forward 2021 is an article
from july of this year quote politico
four wealthy donors fuel overhaul of
california's criminal justice system
the social justice movement has never
lacked for energy last year's police
killing of george floyd sparked waves of
support for blm progressive donors in
recent years have strategically targeted
prosecutor races in major cities because
district attorneys wield power over
sentencing and investigations in
california social justice advocates are
preparing to defend the state's top
prosecutor attorney general rob banta
who is closely aligned with the reform
movement and and was one of the nation's
most liberal ag's
the last 10 years has been the biggest
shift i've seen in terms of
philanthropic interest in this issue
says lenoir anderson who heads
californians for safety and justice when
you have that shift the door is open
because your with the winds have changed
in california few causes get far without
a pile of money ford's owners patty
quillin quinn delaney elizabeth simons
and caitlyn krieger channeled 22 million
dollars to a criminal justice ballot
measures and allied candidates the
previous two years their campaign
contributions have steadily increased
each election cycle they spent 3.7
million dollars alone to elect george
george gascon who wrote the social
justice wave that swept over america
last summer
to unseat incumbent laga jakey jackie
lacy in november
gascon by the way has then proceeded to
completely wreck the city of los angeles
even worse than it was by failing to
prosecute criminals
quillen is a philanthropist and the wife
of netflix ceo reed hastings simons is a
former teacher and daughter of hedge
fund billionaire and philanthropist
james simons krieger and her husband
instagram co-founder mike krieger
running criminal justice nonprofit
okay and of course george soros has
given some money here as well
in 2018 an organization funded by soros
supplied the most money for the
california da races
and by the way this is exactly how san
francisco ends it up with chase a bowden
in san francisco
right bowden is a wild left prosecutor
and because bowden is wild left you end
up with scenes like this so over the
weekend 80 looters simultaneously broke
into a nordstrom near san francisco
here's a little bit of the video
take a look behind me you can see some
of the doors and windows of that louis
vuitton store smashed glass littering
the sidewalk several streets surrounding
union square had to be blocked off and
still are according to a police source
this began as a smash and grab then
turned into a robbery a little after 8
pm spoke to one witness who says that
more than a dozen people could be seen
running out of the store clinging to
merchandise and hauling as much as they
could
at one point sfpd officers could be seen
surrounding a gray convertible mustang
with one patrol car blocking it several
officers taking their batons to smash
out the windows source telling us that
at least one person inside that car had
to be taken to the hospital
okay so people just showing up at louis
vuitton just robbing the place just like
taking the entire place down
according to the washington post drivers
blared their horns saturday evening as
dozens of thieves carrying luggage and
bags started from a nordstrom department
store near san francisco and hopped into
cars waiting for them outside all but
three of the 80 or so looters escaped
police said two store employees were
assaulted one was pepper sprayed by the
intruders according to officers in
walnut creek that's a city about 25
miles east of san francisco
the spectacle saturday night was one of
several incidents of looting and
shoplifting reported at high end retail
stores around the bay area over the
weekend
so the friday night louis vuitton hit
that was in union square on sunday night
officers in hayward about a 30 minute
drive from san francisco were
investigating after a group of smash and
grab burglars destroyed glass cabinets
and stolen merchandise from a mall
jewelry store
san francisco d.a chase a bowden right
one of these lefties elected by george
soros's money said these crimes are
happening around the bay and across the
country i stand in partnership with our
local regional state and federal
partners as we work together to do
whatever it takes to keep you safe
except for arresting criminals and
keeping them in jail because we
obviously wouldn't want an unequal
number of black and white people in jail
forget about who's committing the crimes
the only thing that matters is that we
have an equitable distribution of
convictions that's the only thing that
matters and by equitable they mean
equitable to the racial population not
equitable to the amount of crime that's
being committed
so here's the question how many people
have to die for the equity vision really
how many criminals have to be put out on
the streets because of the vision of
equity because of the lie that if too
many people of one particular race end
up in prison because too many people of
one particular race are committing
crimes this is because the system itself
is racist you can make the argument
there's too much crime in particular
demographics because of history and the
racism of history but making the
argument the system itself is
responsible right now for too many black
people looting louis vuitton is
ridiculous
it's ridiculous on its face and it ends
with more crime and more people being
harmed particularly by the way more
people in the black community is a
generality
now there are consequences to the
narrative the left puts out and those
consequences are incredibly dire
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content